[Applause]
[Music]
it is kind of funny kind of being back
in the dressing room again together we
haven't done that
in almost two years now so but it was it
was sweet you know we feel a lot of
gratitude to be back it was a night of
collapse
it was fun it was a lot of fun amazing
performances
[Music]
if i'm not dripping in sweat by the end
of these shows i did something wrong
and most importantly representation at
last night's cmt awards
to have breland up there to have me up
there and to consistently
show other voices and other sides of
country music like that's the only way
that it's going to change
and it's just it's emotional for me
[Applause]
the knight saw some big winners
including carrie underwood
who won her ninth trophy for video of
the year
thanks to hallelujah her collaboration
with john legend
i'm just really proud of how it turned
out and it was just so beautiful and
just ethereal and spiritual and just all
those things
i'm glad that people thank you but it
was only the show's co-host kane brown
who got to take home
two awards i love fan voted awards
um just because my fans you know they've
been there from day one um
we usually always get something out of
it so i just wanna say i love you guys
and thank you for everything y'all done
for me
not to be forgotten kane's co-host
kelsey ballerini
won her first ever cmt award for
performance of the year
what's important what what do i care
about i just think about if
people that listen to my music and like
what i do are going to like it or not
and that's all i really care about
anymore
and finally shout out to lindsay l who
not only performed
but rocked crutches and a foot cast on
the red carpet a result of chasing after
her dog
when i can wear a sneaker on a red
carpet i am in my happy place